hey guys welcome back to Roseanne's
kitchen table kara still with me what's
going on just enjoying my water in this
mug water and we were faking it and
saying it was coffee that's what
everybody does and it's always water and
there's something about drinking water
out of a mug that's a bit wrong seems
doesn't seem right to you yeah it's a
weird it's a little weird that was good
okay so what I wanted to talk to you
about I have you on and you often talk
about atheists stuff you're my science
chick and my atheist Rick we have to
have a bunt and you know i have actually
a huge atheist community that watches
the show and what I keep saying is why
don't the atheists unite in some kind of
political movement you know 32 it's
starting to happen but like it's just
starting and it seems to me that the
atheists rational people who believe in
science who believe in empirical
evidence could even look at government
in a different way and sort of change
things for the better so i'm waiting for
the atheists too sore to unite so what's
up with the atheists i think what
happens is that they tend to lose the
label atheists when they start to go
political when you see lobbying groups
and when you see political action
committees that are trying to push more
atheists agendas generally speaking
they're going to call themselves secular
groups because they also want to be
friendly to religious communities who
are for the same things atheists don't
need like legislation that's pro atheist
what we need is legislation that is
really keeping to the true nature of the
First Amendment and really separating
church and state and not giving
Christian privilege to organizations in
this country like we have historically
done so a lot of times you will see
these groups that are that are mostly
made up of atheists but they use the
secular label because I think
politically that's a little bit more
important right and I really support
that also I hate to say it but the word
atheist scares the [ __ ] out of people it
really does it bothers me yes I was
literally just podcasting this morning
with Don Johanson who is this amazing
researcher paleoanthropologist who
actually discovered Lucy yeah I just
watched her lip ethicist afarensis their
early hominid and we were talking about
atheism and we're talking about how when
he came out as a
atheist to people he had known his whole
life they would be like he'd be like you
know you know somebody maybe you grew up
with like you know and I don't believe
in God oh and all the cities like I'm
the same person you've known this all
right there is this stigma that's
attached to it now my take is own it own
the label call yourself an atheist show
people that atheists are moral show
people that regular people are atheists
and let's start to take the stigma away
other people shy away from the label
because they don't want to deal with the
negative connotation right so the
Atheist is going to sound kind of silly
but I think I've said this on show board
atheist sort of need to come out of the
closet thank you because even the way
you say a lot coming out of the closet
the way you describe that it sounded
like gays like you need to be what
Harvey Milk used to say that the most
political thing you could do is just
come out because then you change
automatically how your family and your
friends they then see a human and I see
a human and you know it's not that bad
and the truth is in some respects we've
made we have so much more progress to
make but we've made social and political
progress in the LGBT community probably
mostly in the LG community and be but
the T community which is coming oh it's
definitely coming um but we have seen
gay and lesbian individuals in office
atheists and often not until they've
been there for years are they willing to
come out nobody's gonna run and say out
loud that they're an atheist cuz they
won't get elected right so the best
sopla the best example of that actually
is barney frank who was out as a gay man
as a congressman I think starting in
nineteen eighty-two he didn't come out
as an atheist until he had already
resigned and Cirie decided not to run
again political suicide yeah and what
does that say about our culture what
does that say about freedom of religion
or as the Freedom From Religion
Foundation calls it what does it say
about how we really do uphold our
Constitution which is supposed to allow
equal rights I mean it still says one
nation under God on our money and I
think that a lot of our political
decisions are informed by that that
somehow we do have a secular society but
there's this underpinning of religiosity
yeah that that we can't seem to escape
and there's a lot of religious prove
in our laws and that's really
problematic and I think that that's what
we need to be fighting yeah do you think
that the Atheist community sort of needs
some new leaders or some like younger
leaders or something like that because
you know I talk a lot about that whole
thing with with Bill Maher and Ben
Affleck and sam Harris and it seemed to
me there was a real moment I could feel
it online of like atheists kind of be
unlike man we're sick of being [ __ ] on
and we're sick of being misrepresented
and then I saw atheists being attacked
these new atheist people calling the
militant atheist I'm like I just don't
see it I don't see atheists harming
anyone I just don't see them oppressing
anyone or anything like that yeah and I
saw everything being flipped on them and
I just kept thinking wow why isn't there
sort of organized why isn't there more
of and I guess maybe that's part of it
that if people are based in rationality
inside you it's hard to gin up the crowd
right is that it's partially that but
it's partially because atheists are not
monolithic so for example people who are
Methodists have a similar ideology and
they bond together they band together
because of that ideology by definition
atheists lack of belief it's not that we
all don't believe in god it's that we
it's not that we all believe that there
is no God is that we all just don't
believe in God weird you're lacking
belief so it's like it's like defining a
whole bunch of people by a negative and
then saying you're similar band together
and join up in a group a lot of people
are actually against the idea of
organizing as atheists because they say
it's like it's like herding cats it's
like trying to organize as anarchists
there's nothing I learned so on one hand
while I think it would make some sense
politically there's probably I think
what you're saying is there's probably
no reason to think that they would all
not all of course but that even a
majority of atheists would want the same
political systems within the within the
community but beyond that I think that
many atheists do understand the need for
atheist activism and they understand the
need for being out loud and being proud
but at the same time you mentioned
Harvey Milk I think that it is important
to point out I think that you would
probably agree with me although it's the
strongest thing you could do politically
to come out and to be open and to where
the banner with pride I also would never
tell somebody what to do but their own
personal life there's plenty of people
still in this country who
in areas where coming out as an atheist
would be unsafe and I would never say
that it's your responsibility to your
community to put yourself in in danger
because of that yeah well I think we can
agree on that are you an atheist are you
a believer are you half and half what
are you let us know in the comments
right down below